how are you very good to see you we were
just talking both of you in past roles
have had done so much training so much
choreography and kicked so much ass with
precision totally wimpy sloppy and none
of us want to hurt the other one you
know it's a hardcore fight between two
people who don't want to take a punch or
give a punch - oh he's very funny right
- sort of not be the thing that kids
look at and go I want to do that no it's
the thing that kids look at and go he
would been impressive but no it was
wonderful to be involved in the fight
where the choreography was we made we
made up a lot you know every fight
should always have a story to it this
one yes I have to ask you your thoughts
on I mean you guys are on the carpet now
in a couple hours it's walking Phoenix
with Joker what's your take on yeah yeah
walking is one of the best actors around
you know and obviously I worked with
Heath and you know you know there's a
brave thing to follow up that
performance yeah and he always makes
really interesting choices and you know
the dynasty I wish them wish them the
best with that and has Robert Pattinson
reached out to you at all oh yes you
know I think he's a fantastic choice I
need interesting I said yes yes
absolutely
thank you so much congratulations on
this really appreciate your time welcome
back everyone is Charlie happy Batman
day so in honor of Batman day this is
gonna be a video all about Christian
Bale reacting to the Joker movie a
general comparison of Joaquin Phoenix's
Joker to Heath Ledger's Joker in Dark
Knight and just a general non-spoilery
reaction review the movie I have had a
chance to see it so no worries no
spoilers in this video and because
tickets are going on sale this next week
we'll do a giveaway for tickets all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite Joker on the
video so part of the reason why you're
hearing Christian Bale talk about so
much Batman stuff is because all the
Batman characters are all over the place
again right now between the Joker movie
the Harley Quinn birds-of-prey movie now
the new Robert Pattinson Batman movie so
you'll see a lot more of the former
Batman actors or people that have been
in Batman films as big character
talking about all the new stuff in the
next year and even though you kind of
expect these big actors to be at least a
little political and the way they talk
about the new stuff they do seem
genuinely honest with all the praises
that they're singing of at least a new
Joker film no one has really seen the
new birds-of-prey films so we can't
really say a whole lot about that yet
but Christian Bale is just the most
recent example that pretty soon you'll
hear people going back to Mark Hamill
for his reaction on the movie because he
hasn't seen it yet but his Joker from
Batman in the animated series is one of
the best versions of the Joker of all
time in fact the way Mark Hamill talks
about how he crafted his version of the
Joker back in the 90s is very similar to
the way that Joaquin Phoenix described
how he found his way into the new Joker
I didn't think I could do it and I I was
kind of practiced alone but I asked Todd
to come over to audition my laughs
because I felt like I had to be able to
do it like on the spot and in front of
somebody else I didn't want to fake it I
had to like find it and you said I said
you know you have the part right you
don't have to but he he really found it
was a process I think for him finding
not to speak for him but finding that
laugh and sort of the modulation of it
and you know in the movie there's really
three or four different laughs there's
the kind of affliction laughs then
there's the laugh where he's trying to
be one of the guys or one of the crowd
and then to me there's the laugh at the
end which is authentic joy so there's
these sort of modulations on it which we
talked a lot about - he was all about
the laugh Mark Hamill found the laugh
burst that was his into his version of
the Joker
Joaquin Phoenix also started with the
laugh but focusing on the main
differences between Heath Ledger's Joker
and Joaquin Phoenix's Joker is their
psychology so remember during the dark
night when the Joker first started
meeting with the Gotham mob bosses they
instantly branded him as just another
random crazy clown you're insane and he
replied very calmly no I'm not crazy as
if he was the least crazy person in that
room one
see a magic trick he was doing all these
things in the name of chaos and general
mayhem but Heath Ledger's Joker was not
a person who was clinically insane or
suffering from a traditional
psychological disorder Alfred said it
best some men just want to watch the
world burn he was a character that was
trying to turn the camera around on the
citizens of Gotham to try and force
Batman to see that they were just as bad
as any of the other villains he tells
Batman when the chips are down these
good people of Gotham they'll eat each
other alive that winds up culminating in
his gambit during the final act trying
to make these two separate groups of
people on the barges kill the other in
order to survive would you kill someone
else to save yourself kind of thing even
though the Dark Knight is a pretty
intense film it had a more optimistic
ending when the criminals people branded
as the worst of the worst step up to
prevent a seemingly normal citizen from
committing that terrible act so the
thesis of the Dark Knight trilogy is
that even quote-unquote bad people of
Gotham are fundamentally good when faced
with life-or-death situations the
joaquin phoenix joker on the flip side
of that psychology starts out as a
relatively normal person who then
suffers from severe psychological
disorders his lap that Joker cackles
that you hear in all the trailers is
actually part of his condition it's not
a spoiler to say that it's like a
Tourette's style condition he can't
control it and it just comes out
whenever he's under extremely stressful
situations
he'll just automatically start laughing
uncontrollably like that and he
described the laughter as something
that's almost painful and so ultimately
I think that it's it is Joker it's a
part of him that's trying to emerge
right and I thought that was a really
interesting way of looking at this
laughs because I think we all kind of
assume what a joker laugh is and it felt
like it was a new fresh way of looking
at it the movie does take the time to
explain why he'd developed that
condition but when you watch the
trailers you see all these things in
Gotham getting crazier and crazier as
the music starts to crescendo he slowly
starts donning the iconic Joker makeup
that's all misleading and making it seem
like he's similar to Heath Ledger's
Joker in that his goal might be to
create chaos but that's not what's
actually going on he's not trying to
create chaos out of some sadistic sense
of pleasure it's not a spoiler to say
that Batman isn't in the movie so he has
no traditional enemy in a
comic-book sense that he's after he's
not crafting some grand plan to destroy
the city of Gotham out of revenge so
when you hear people talking about what
an amazing character study the movie is
on the Joker through Joaquin Phoenix's
performance this Joker is someone you
watch turn into the Joker because of the
things that the world does to him how
tragic that is you're meant to
sympathize with them like he's the hero
of the movie even though he does
terrible terrible things he's definitely
a villain but he's more of a tragic
villain in that sense eventually
throughout the movie you start to see
almost everyone else in his life at
various points start to see more and
more like the real villains of the story
whereas in the Dark Knight there was no
question the whole time Joker is evil at
the start of the movie Joker is evil at
the end of the movie Batman is the hero
the hero has to defeat the villain part
of the reason why the Joker movie is
getting so much attention and is such a
surprise is because it sort of turns
those ideas on their head the movie
questions the role of society in
creating the Joker how we demonize
mental health issues how we let people
down who desperately need our help
Joaquin Phoenix's Joker does not start
out as a villain but no one gives him
the help he needs and that's really when
things start to go off the rails it's
still a comic book movie so there are a
lot of Easter eggs for Joker comic book
stories like The Killing Joke what was
fun about it was we were able to kind of
pick and choose certain elements from
the comic book past the past comic books
and used kind of what we wanted here and
maybe we'll use a little bit of that so
there's a little bit I guess of Killing
Joke with the idea of a wanna of a
failed stand-up comedian speaking of The
Killing Joke Mark Hamill did the
animated version of that movie and
during that story joker has his famous
one bad day speech that he gives to
Batman you're one bad day away from
being me there's a little bit of that
energy behind the Joker movie like I
started out as a mostly normal person
this could happen to any of you it's all
a big joke
[Music]
I demonstrated there's no difference
between me and everyone else all the
takes is one bad day that's how far the
world is from where I am just one bad
day you had a bad day once am i right
I can tell you had a bad day
Joaquin Phoenix's story during the Joker
movie turns into this really powerful
performance that makes you question a
lot of your assumptions and that's part
of the reason why you see people talking
about the movie being nominated for a
bunch of Oscars getting a bunch of
awards attention which i think is great
it's always awesome to hear about comic
book movies being nominated for big
awards I don't know if it'll actually
win any because usually comic book
movies like Black Panther for instance
the win awards usually win technical
awards for production design for casting
for stuff like that so we'll see but
tickets are going on sale next week so
be sure to go see the movie when you
have the opportunity and once you do let
me know in the comments what you thought
of it I'll wait to do my full review
Easter eggs and all those kinds of
videos till the movie actually does come
out in theaters to give people a chance
to see it but if you have special
requests for Joker or Batman videos just
let me know in the comments I'll name a
giveaway winner when I post a new DC
video everybody click here for that new
flash season 6 trailer with Tom Welling
coming back is Superman from Smallville
and click here for my brand new Titans
Nightwing trailer video thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
happy Batman day
[Music]